hey guys my name is Eve my dad is a good
dog dad his name is Chris and he makes
video sometimes and today I thought I'd
make one of my own I'm gonna go react to
the show dog strangler come on let's go
okay here we go
oh that that's the dog is rapping I
don't think dogs were happening this is
already I'm not on board I gotta be
honest this looks like to be
completely honest I think I'd rather get
my balls when then watch this yeah I
don't think I could ever actually sit
through this and I eat underwear so what
do I know maybe I can convince my poor
dad to skip this one mmm
watch show dogs or take a bath take 10
baths I'm gonna tell my dad I am finally
ready to go to the vet I've picked may
18th for my appointment day honestly I'd
rather eat my own than watch this
yeah I'm not gonna lie I think I'd
rather hump a tree
[Music]
oh my god I need a treat right now well
I just gonna say uh thanks for watching
the video um yeah it was fun to make
this and subscribe to my dad's channel
you know he's a good guy I like him a
lot
he gives me food and treats
[Music]